tengo aquí este problema del examen en
mi del 2003 el cual es uno de los
mejores exámenes que se aplican a las
competencias matemáticas que existen en
eeuu que por cierto es el problema
número uno y dice el producto n de 3
entre los positivos es 6 veces su suma
en uno de estos enteros positivos es la
suma de los otros dos encuentra la suma
de todos los posibles valores de n así
que vamos a resolverlo y lo primero que
voy a hacer es escribir a estos tres
enteros positivos así que voy a decir
que a b y c son precisamente estos tres
enteros positivos que yo tengo muy bien
y ahora qué datos me dan lo primero que
me dicen es que el producto de estos
tres enteros positivos es decir a por b
por sem es igual a n que por cierto esto
es lo mismo a 6 veces la suma de estos
tres centros positivos así que déjame
ponerlo con otro color esto que estoy
poniendo de color morado es justo lo que
está diciendo una ecuación aquí abajo de
color morado del mismo color
aporté porsche es igual a n y por otra
parte tengo que esto es igual a 6
es la suma de a b c es decir 6 veces la
suma de sus tres entre los positivos y
después dice uno de ellos es la suma de
los otros dos uno de estos enteros
positivos es la suma de los otros dos
así que sin pérdida de generalidad me
voy a tomar hace puede ser cualquiera de
estos dos pero recuerda que son nombres
así que pues mi elegido va a ser sem se
va a ser el entero el cual es la suma de
los otros dos por lo tanto a más ben es
igual hace aquí ya estoy utilizando la
segunda frase y después me dice
encuentra la suma de todos los posibles
valores de n así que lo primero que voy
a hacer es ya que tengo aquí el valor de
cm pues porque no lo sustituimos en esta
ecuación que tengo aquí arriba ya sé que
a más b es igual a cero entonces voy a
tomar el valor de cm y lo voy a
sustituir tanto aquí como aquí y así al
menos reducir un poco toda esta ecuación
que tengo aquí arriba si te das cuenta
ya con esto voy a pasar a tener una
expresión con dos incógnitas en lugar de
con tres incógnitas por lo tanto me va a
quedar a por b
pero en este caso lo voy a escribir como
ven a por b por c entonces lo que daría
por ver que multiplica
esto es igual a n que por cierto es
igual a 6 veces a más ve más se ha más b
pero en lugar de s voy a escribir a más
b
recuerda que pse es igual a más b por lo
tanto seis veces más ven más a más ven y
entonces esta ecuación que por cierto
esto es lo mismo que n ya la podemos
reducir un poco porque aquí en este lado
derecho tengo seis veces más ve más a
más b lo cual es dos veces más dos veces
bien o dicho de otra manera inclusive
esto lo podemos ver si sacamos como
factor común el 2 como 6 por 2 que son
12 12 veces más b si saco como factor
común al 2 no quedaría seis por dos
programas bien es decir 12 programas y
esto es igual a por b que multiplica a
su vez a más ver que por cierto el valor
de ese entonces me queda por ver que
multiplica a más veces igualdad 12 por a
más
y a mí se me ocurre que aquí podemos
cancelar a más ve tengo a más
multiplicando tanto a por ver cómo va a
12 por lo tanto qué te parece ese
cancelamos a más ven dividiendo ambos
lados de la ecuación entre ambas ve y
entonces si yo canceló a más ver
solamente me voy a quedar con que a por
ben es igual a 12 y esto me va a servir
bastante así que dejamos comentó aquí
abajo
si yo canceló este ya éste me queda que
a por bent
es igual a 12 y ya casi tenemos la
solución de este problema porque fíjate
muy bien con mucho ojo porque aquí está
es lo más importante estamos buscando
dos enteros positivos que su
multiplicación sea 12 pues a ver vamos a
pensarlo tantito voy a poner aquí a am a
b ya sé ya está aquí al final voy a
poner aa por ver por csn me voy a fijar
en dos enteros positivos que su
multiplicación sea 12 pues los primeros
que se te pueden ocurrir es 1 y 12 1 por
2 es 12 y 1 más 12 es 13 entonces se
vale 13 y si yo multiplico 1 por 12 por
13 esto es lo mismo que 12 por 12 que
144 más 12 que es
156 ya está puedes verificar que
realmente sí funcione porque fíjate bien
si sumó uno más 12-13 pues esto es lo
mismo que 26 y 6 por 26
156 que es justo lo que quería y lo que
me dice el problema pero todo esto por
esta construcción que acabo de hacer muy
bien ya tengo una hay una vez que son
enteros positivos tales que su
multiplicación sea 12 ahora me voy a
fijar en 2 y 6 2 por 6 es 12 26 8 y 2
por 6 12 por 8 estos 96 vuelve a cumplir
otra vez todo 2006 es 88 16 por 66 96 y
los últimos que nos faltan es 34 3 por 4
es 12 y 34 es 7 entonces 3 por 4 es 12
por 7 es 84 de cros estoy diciendo de
más aportes siempre es 12 12 por 7 es 84
y bueno igualmente si sumó tres más 4
714 14 por 6 es 84 muy bien y ahora lo
que quiero que veas es que ya no existen
más enteros positivos a ive tales que su
multiplicación sea 12 ya tenemos
todas las posibles combinaciones o eyes
1 y best 12
2 y b6 oa estrés y bs 4 no hay más
este es el paso más importante de este
problema súper difícil darte cuenta que
no existe otra posibilidad y ahora
fíjate bien lo que me piden es la suma
de todos posibles valores de n y como es
de s n entonces vamos a sumar esto y ya
acabamos el problema 6 +6 es 12 416
llevamos una 9 y unas son 10 y una son
15 y 8 son 23 sirvan 23 sin 23 llevamos
2 y después 12 13 336 y ya está la
respuesta de este problema es 336